- Witaj ponownie w „Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation". Nazywam się John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym
ds. edukacji w IBM Quantum.
To jest piąta lekcja z serii i pierwsza lekcja
w drugiej jednostce serii, która dotyczy algorytmów kwantowych.
W tej jednostce zbadamy
obliczeniowe zalety informacji kwantowej, czyli przyjrzymy się temu, co możemy zrobić
z komputerami kwantowymi i jakie zalety komputery kwantowe mogą potencjalnie mieć
nad komputerami klasycznymi.
Skupimy się na tym, co możemy zrobić z jednym komputerem kwantowym, w przeciwieństwie do ustawienia rozproszonego,
na przykład,
gdzie wiele komputerów kwantowych współdziała przez sieć pewnego rodzaju.
Istnieją w rzeczywistości kwantowe przewagi w ustawieniach rozproszonych, gdzie komunikacja
i kryptografia odgrywają rolę,
ale nie będziemy
omawiać tych kwestii w tej jednostce.
Ta jednostka dotyczy algorytmów kwantowych działających na pojedynczych komputerach kwantowych.
Zacznijmy od naturalnego pytania. Jakie zalety może potencjalnie oferować
komputer kwantowy?
Główną jest to, że komputery kwantowe mogą zapewniać szybsze rozwiązania niektórych problemów obliczeniowych.
Czas jest cenny i choć komputery, których
używamy na co dzień, są całkiem szybkie, wciąż są zbyt wolne,
aby rozwiązać pewne problemy obliczeniowe, właśnie ze względu na wrodzoną
trudność obliczeniową tych problemów.
Ten potencjał, że komputery kwantowe mogą pozwolić nam rozwiązywać problemy, których klasyczne komputery
są zbyt wolne, aby rozwiązać,
jest tym, co napędza
badania nad algorytmami kwantowymi przez ostatnie kilka dekad.
Istnieją inne zasoby obliczeniowe
oprócz czasu, które można brać pod uwagę, jak ilość pamięci komputerowej wymagana do obliczeń,
ale komputery kwantowe nie mogą
zaoferować zbyt dużych oszczędności pod względem pamięci, jak się okazuje, a klasyczna pamięć komputerowa jest całkiem tania
szczególnie w porównaniu z pamięcią kwantową. Więc po prostu nie ma
tutaj zbyt wielkich perspektyw.
Możemy też pomyśleć o innych zasobach, jak ilość energii
potrzebnej do obliczeń, ale w rzeczywistości
wcale nie potrzebujesz dużo energii
do klasycznych obliczeń, szczególnie jeśli jesteś
gotowy zwolnić tempo.
Więc to rzeczywiście czas
wymagany do obliczeń jest naszym głównym celem.
Oto przegląd lekcji, która dotyczy konkretnego
modelu obliczeniowego zwanego modelem zapytań.
Możesz myśleć o tym modelu jak o swego rodzaju szalce Petriego do rozwijania pomysłów algorytmicznych, zarówno kwantowych, jak i klasycznych.
Nie ma być praktycznym modelem opisującym rodzaje
problemów obliczeniowych, które napotykamy w prawdziwym życiu.
W kolejnych lekcjach tej jednostki odejdziemy od modelu zapytań i skupimy się zamiast tego na modelach inspirowanych bardziej praktycznymi
pojęciami obliczeń,
ale model zapytań jest
bardzo dobrym punktem startowym.
To prosty model, który pozwala nam badać
potencjał komputerów kwantowych bez zagłębiania się w mnóstwo szczegółów technicznych,
a także pozwala nam wyodrębnić niektóre
naprawdę ważne idee stojące za obliczeniami kwantowymi i tym, jak działają.
Obliczenia kwantowe faktycznie po raz pierwszy rozwinęły się w tym modelu, a idee, które
w nim powstały, bezpośrednio zainspirowały
ważne algorytmy kwantowe
takie jak algorytm Shora dla faktoryzacji.
W pierwszej sekcji lekcji przyjrzymy się konkretnie temu, czym jest model zapytań obliczeniowych,
a w drugiej, trzeciej
i czwartej sekcji omówimy trzy
kwantowe algorytmy zapytań, mianowicie algorytm Deutscha,
algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy
i algorytm Simona, które ujawniają coraz
bardziej imponujące zalety
komputerów kwantowych
nad klasycznymi w modelu zapytań obliczeniowych.
Aby wyjaśnić model zapytań obliczeniowych, zacznijmy najpierw od bardziej standardowej
abstrakcji obliczeń.
Oto rysunek, który
przedstawia obliczenia w bardzo prostych i podstawowych pojęciach.
Mamy dane wejściowe, które zazwyczaj przyjmują
postać ciągu binarnego, choć moglibyśmy używać innych
symboli, gdybyśmy chcieli.
Dane wejściowe są przekazywane do obliczeń, które są reprezentowane przez niebieski
prostokąt na tym rysunku,
a wynikiem obliczeń jest to, że produkowane są pewne dane wyjściowe, które znowu najczęściej
są ciągiem binarnym.
Oczywiście ten rysunek
nie jest wcale szczegółowy co do tego, jak działają same obliczenia.
Możemy formułować różne
szczegółowe modele obliczeniowe, aby to zrobić, takie jak maszyny Turinga
i circuit boolowski,
lub quantum circuit, jeśli myślimy o
obliczeniach kwantowych.
Prawdą jest, że ten rysunek
nie odzwierciedla faktu, że wiele
komputerów, których używamy na co dzień, stale odbiera
dane wejściowe i produkuje wyjściowe,
zasadniczo wchodząc w interakcję z nami i innymi komputerami przez
internet na przykład.
Ale nie próbujemy tutaj reprezentować
tych interakcji.
Chodzi o modelowanie
izolowanych zadań obliczeniowych.
Na przykład dane wejściowe mogą być
binarnym kodowaniem liczby lub reprezentacją macierzy
WEBVTT
lub opisem cząsteczki, albo czymkolwiek innym, co mamy na myśli, i jest jakieś zadanie obliczeniowe
wykonywane tylko na tych danych wejściowych.
Kluczowym punktem jest to, że
całość danych wejściowych jest przekazywana do obliczeń i nic z danych wejściowych
nie jest przed nimi ukryte.
Model zapytań
działa inaczej.
W modelu zapytań dane wejściowe są udostępniane
w postaci funkcji, do której obliczenia mogą
uzyskać dostęp, wykonując zapytania,
lub innymi słowy, ewaluując funkcję
na różnych danych wejściowych.
Tu możesz zobaczyć to reprezentowane
w formie rysunku.
Podobnie jak wcześniej, obliczenia są reprezentowane
przez niebieski prostokąt, ale zamiast bezpośrednio otrzymywać dane wejściowe
w postaci ciągu
bitów na przykład, uzyskuje dostęp do danych wejściowych, efektywnie zadając pytania
i otrzymując odpowiedzi.
Czasami używamy
terminów „wyrocznia" i „czarna skrzynka" w odniesieniu do mechanizmu,
który dostarcza dane wejściowe.
Istnieje różnica między
wyrocznią a czarną skrzynką w teorii złożoności, ale nie będzie to istotne dla celów tej dyskusji.
Tak czy inaczej, te terminy mają
przekazywać podstawową ideę.
W starożytnej Grecji można było
pójść do wyroczni, jak Wyrocznie w Delfach,
i zadać ważne pytanie,
a wyrocznia odpowiadałaby
na to konkretne pytanie, ale z pewnością nie powiedziałaby ci wszystkiego, co wiedziała.
Podobnie, gdy
myślimy o czarnej skrzynce, mamy na myśli jakiś
rodzaj procesu lub systemu,
gdzie możemy wybrać, co wchodzi, i możemy zobaczyć, co wychodzi, ale nie mamy żadnego zrozumienia
jego wewnętrznych mechanizmów.
I tak jest w tym przypadku. Dane wejściowe do problemu
przyjmują postać funkcji i wszystko, co możemy zrobić, to
ewaluować tę funkcję,
ale poza tym nie mamy
żadnej wiedzy ani zrozumienia tego, jak działa.
Przez całą lekcję
będziemy rezerwować literę f dla funkcji, która
reprezentuje dane wejściowe, i przyjmiemy założenie,
że zawsze przyjmuje
postać, którą widzisz tutaj.
Sigma oznacza alfabet binarny, więc f jest funkcją z ciągów
bitów do ciągów bitów,
a konkretnie przyjmiemy, że
dane wejściowe do f to ciąg bitów o długości n, a wyjście to ciąg
bitów o długości m,
gdzie n i m są dodatnimi liczbami całkowitymi.
Dla różnych problemów będziemy
mieli ograniczenia na n i m, ale we wszystkich przypadkach funkcja wejściowa będzie
miała taką postać.
Kiedy mówimy, że
obliczenie wykonuje zapytanie, mamy na myśli to, że funkcja f jest ewaluowana raz,
to znaczy pewien ciąg x o długości N jest wybierany przez obliczenia, a ciąg f(x) jest
następnie udostępniany
przez wyrocznię lub czarną skrzynkę. I wreszcie, bardzo prosty sposób mierzenia kosztu obliczeniowego
algorytmu zapytań to liczenie, ile zapytań wymaga.
Choć prawdą jest, że
naprawdę najbardziej interesuje nas to, jak długo trwają obliczenia, gdy badamy model zapytań,
generalnie upraszczamy sprawy
i po prostu liczymy zapytania, i tak właśnie zrobimy w tej lekcji.
Teraz przyjrzyjmy się
kilku przykładom problemów zapytań, czyli problemom obliczeniowym w modelu zapytań,
i tutaj, nawiasem mówiąc, po prostu opiszę
same problemy, i na tym etapie nic nie powiem
o tym, jak je rozwiązać.
Pierwszym problemem jest problem OR.
W tym przypadku dane wejściowe to funkcja
z n bitów do zaledwie 1 bitu, więc m jest równe 1 dla tego problemu,
a wymagane dane wyjściowe
dla problemu to 1 lub 0.
Jeśli istnieje jakiś ciąg n bitów x, dla którego f(x) jest równe 1, to prawidłowa odpowiedź to 1,
a w przeciwnym razie, jeśli f(x) jest
zawsze 0 dla każdego ciągu x, to prawidłowa odpowiedź to 0.
Więc jeśli myślimy o funkcji f jako zapewniającej nam losowy
dostęp do 2 do n bitów, po jednym dla każdego ciągu x o n bitach,
to o co chodzi, to
OR tych bitów, i dlatego nazywa się to problemem OR.
Innym przykładem jest problem parzystości, który jest podobny do problemu OR, z wyjątkiem że pyta o parzystość,
lub innymi słowy, o XOR (alternatywę wykluczającą) wszystkich jednobitrowych
wartości wyjściowych funkcji.
Inny sposób, aby to powiedzieć, to
że prawidłowa odpowiedź to 0, jeśli liczba ciągów n bitów x, dla których f(x) jest równe 1, jest parzysta,
a prawidłowa odpowiedź to
1, jeśli ta liczba jest nieparzysta.
Przykładem problemu, w którym m niekoniecznie jest równe 1, jest problem minimum.
Tutaj funkcja f przyjmuje zwykłą postać i nie ma ograniczeń na n i m,
a prawidłowa odpowiedź to cokolwiek wyjście
funkcji pojawia się jako pierwsze w leksykograficznym
lub słownikowym porządku
ciągów binarnych. Alternatywnie, jeśli chcesz
myśleć o ciągach długości m jako reprezentujących nieujemne
liczby całkowite w zapisie binarnym,
to prawidłowa odpowiedź
to najmniejsza możliwa lub minimalna wartość, która
wychodzi z tej funkcji.
WEBVTT
Czasami rozważamy też problemy zapytań, gdzie mamy obietnicę
dotyczącą funkcji wejściowej, lub innymi słowy, pewną
gwarancję co do niej,
i nie martwimy się o funkcje, które tej obietnicy nie spełniają.
Funkcje, które nie spełniają obietnicy, są traktowane jako dane wejściowe „nie dbamy o to".
I po prostu nie ponosimy odpowiedzialności za to, co dzieje się na tych danych wejściowych.
Oto przykład problemu zapytań z obietnicą, zwanego unikatowym wyszukiwaniem.
Jest powiązany z problemem OR,
ale jest inny.
Funkcja wejściowa ma tę samą
postać co dla problemu OR, tzn. przyjmuje
ciągi n bitów do bitów.
Tym razem obiecujemy sobie, że
istnieje dokładnie jeden ciąg Z, który powoduje, że f przyjmuje wartość 1,
przy czym f(x) jest równe 0
dla każdego ciągu x poza z, a prawidłowe wyjście
to ten unikatowy ciąg z.
Oczywiście istnieją
wybory funkcji f, które nie spełniają tego warunku, ale nie stawiamy żadnych wymagań
wobec algorytmów dla tego problemu, gdy otrzymują takie
funkcje jako dane wejściowe.
Zależy nam tylko na funkcjach, które spełniają obietnicę.
Teraz, wszystkie cztery
problemy, które właśnie wymieniłem, są całkiem naturalne, co oznacza, że łatwo je wyjaśnić,
i łatwo sobie wyobrazić sytuacje, w których może pojawić się potrzeba ich rozwiązania, ale niektóre problemy zapytań
wcale takie nie są.
W rzeczywistości czasami rozważamy wysoce
sztuczne problemy zapytań, gdzie trudno sobie wyobrazić, że ktokolwiek kiedykolwiek
naprawdę chciałby je rozwiązać.
Problem Simona, który
zobaczymy później w lekcji, trochę wpisuje się w tę kategorię, ale są też inne
które są w pewnym sensie znacznie gorsze, ale mimo to faktycznie okazują się dość ważne dla badania modelu zapytań.
Nie badamy tych problemów, ponieważ koniecznie chcemy
je rozwiązywać w praktyce.
Można o tym myśleć tak, że szukamy
ekstremów różnego rodzaju,
w szczególności, gdy pracujemy w
tej szalce Petriego jako modelu, naturalnym sposobem eksploracji
kwantowych idei algorytmicznych
jest formułowanie wysoce sztucznych problemów, gdzie możemy najlepiej wykorzystać
moc komputerów kwantowych.
I to może w rzeczywistości
rzucić dużo światła na to, jak komputery kwantowe
mogą być potencjalnie przydatne w bardziej praktycznych ustawieniach.
Możemy sformalizować pojęcie
zapytania na różne sposoby w zależności od modelu obliczeniowego, z którym pracujemy.
Na przykład w modelu maszyny Turinga
obliczeń, o którym nie rozmawialiśmy i nie będziemy go omawiać w tej serii,
istnieje pewien sposób
formalizacji pojęcia zapytania, który ma sens dla tego modelu.
Dla modeli circuit definiujemy specjalne typy
gate'ów zwane query gate'ami i w ten sposób zapytania
są formalnie reprezentowane.
Dla Boolean circuits istnieje bardzo prosty sposób to zrobić, który polega po prostu na wyobrażeniu sobie, że mamy query gate'y
które ewaluują funkcję wejściową bezpośrednio, jak możesz zobaczyć tutaj na ekranie.
Idea polega na tym, że możemy
używać tych query gate'ów do budowania circuit'ów, które rozwiązują jakikolwiek
problem, który rozważamy,
i aby działać poprawnie, circuit'y muszą dać właściwą odpowiedź dla jakiejkolwiek funkcji wejściowej f,
zakładając, że spełnia ona obietnicę w przypadku problemu z obietnicą.
Oto prosty przykład
Boolean circuit, który rozwiązuje problem
parzystości, gdy n jest równe 1,
więc funkcja wejściowa f jest z
1 bitu do 1 bitu w tym przypadku.
To, co ten circuit robi, to ewaluuje funkcję
f na wejściach 0 i 1, używając tych dwóch query gate'ów.
Następnie podłącza dwie wartości wyjściowe, które
otrzymuje z query gate'ów, do Boolean circuit z lekcji trzeciej, który oblicza XOR,
co jest tym samym, co parzystość.
Żeby było jasne, te dwie
wartości wejściowe tutaj nie są wejściami do problemu,
czyli problemu parzystości,
gdy pracujemy z modelem zapytań, dane wejściowe do problemu
to funkcja f, i powinieneś myśleć o tych
dwóch wejściach do circuit'u
jako wartościach zakodowanych
na stałe, które nigdy się nie zmieniają, są zasadniczo częścią algorytmu.
Chcemy obliczyć XOR z f(0) i f(1), więc zainicjowaliśmy te
dwa przewody w ten sposób,
żeby to działało. Użyliśmy dwóch query gate'ów
tutaj, tego i tego,
i tak algorytm reprezentowany
przez ten Boolean circuit wykonuje dwa zapytania, a jeśli przez chwilę pomyślimy o problemie parzystości
dla funkcji z jednego bitu do jednego bitu, widzimy, że jest to absolutnie konieczne dla każdego Boolean circuit,
który rozwiązuje ten problem,
aby wykonać co najmniej dwa zapytania.
Jeśli wykonasz tylko jedno zapytanie, tak że znasz tylko jedną
wartość wyjściową funkcji f, a nie drugą, tak naprawdę nie masz
żadnej informacji
o parzystości, ponieważ druga wartość wyjściowa
może równie dobrze być 0 lub 1, prowadząc do któregokolwiek z dwóch możliwych rozwiązań
problemu. Więc pod względem liczby
zapytań, które wykonuje, ten Boolean circuit jest tak dobry, jak tylko można
w przypadku problemu parzystości
gdy n jest równe 1.
WEBVTT
Jest jeszcze jedna kwestia dotycząca query gate'ów, którą warto wspomnieć zanim przejdziemy dalej, a mianowicie to, że gdy projektujemy i analizujemy algorytmy zapytań,
wcale nie martwimy się o to, jak
query gate'y są implementowane.
Zakłada się, że te
query gate'y są nam dane i trudność ich budowania
nie jest naszą sprawą.
Możesz myśleć o samych
query gate'ach jako o danych wejściowych, jeśli chcesz, i nie naszą pracą jest tworzenie danych wejściowych, staramy się tylko
rozwiązać konkretny problem
mając dane wejściowe. Oczywiście gdy f jest funkcją
z jednego bitu do jednego bitu, istnieją tylko cztery możliwe wybory,
i byłoby łatwo
zaimplementować każdy z nich, ale ogólnie, dla funkcji
z wieloma bitami wejściowymi,
implementacja query gate'ów
dla tych funkcji mogłaby być niezwykle trudna.
Żeby było jasne, nie chodzi o to,
że kwestia implementacji query gate'ów jest nieważna, ale raczej że nie jest brana pod uwagę
jako część kosztu
algorytmu zapytań.
Jest to spójne z ideą, że chodzi tu nie tyle o praktyczne obliczenia czy faktyczne budowanie circuit'ów jako takich,
ale o pracę w
ramach teoretycznych, które mówią nam interesujące
rzeczy o obliczeniach.
Będziemy mieli więcej do powiedzenia na ten temat, gdy przejdziemy z tego modelu do bardziej standardowego modelu obliczeń, i to jest głównie o tym kolejna lekcja,
lekcja 6.
Teraz skupmy się
na quantum circuit'ach.
Dla quantum circuit'ów zamierzamy zmienić
definicję query gate'ów, aby były unitarne.
Chcemy móc wykonywać
zapytania w ramach quantum circuit'ów i aby działały
liniowo na stanach kwantowych,
tak abyśmy mogli efektywnie
wykonywać zapytania w superpozycji.
Może się wydawać, że przestawiamy
bramki, że tak powiem, zmieniając znaczenie zapytania w porównaniu do tego, co właśnie
widzieliśmy dla Boolean circuit'ów,
ale istnieje uzasadnienie tego, które omówimy bardziej
szczegółowo w następnej lekcji.
Na razie to po prostu definicja.
Konkretnie, definicja
jest następująca: dla dowolnej funkcji f o
tej samej postaci co wcześniej,
co oznacza, że odwzorowuje ciągi
n bitów na ciągi m bitów, query gate Uf działa na n + m qubit'ach
i jest zdefiniowany przez
akcję opisaną tutaj na stanach standardowej bazy.
Za chwilę zobaczymy rysunek
przedstawiający tę definicję, ale najpierw wyjaśnię notację,
która jest tu używana,
a mianowicie zawsze gdy
używamy symbolu XOR jako operacji między dwoma
ciągami tej samej długości,
mamy na myśli
bitowy XOR, i tutaj możesz zobaczyć przykład.
W definicji mamy, że zarówno y, jak i f(x) są ciągami długości m, więc ten ciąg tutaj
reprezentuje ciąg, który otrzymujemy
przez XORowanie tych dwóch ciągów
razem, bit po bicie, i oto diagram
wyjaśniający, jak działają te gate'y.
Górne n qubit'ów odpowiada
argumentowi funkcji.
I gdy zaczną
w stanie standardowej bazy, ket x w tym diagramie, ten stan standardowej bazy
przechodzi niezmieniony
i jest odbijany jako część wyjścia.
Dolne m qubit'ów odpowiada wyjściu
funkcji f, i gdy zaczną
w dowolnym stanie standardowej bazy,
ket y w tym diagramie, co się dzieje, to wyjście funkcji f(x) jest XORowane na ciąg y.
To dzieje się dla
stanów standardowej bazy, a jeśli chcemy wiedzieć,
co dzieje się ogólnie dla innych stanów kwantowych, używamy liniowości, jak zawsze.
Powodem zdefiniowania query gate'ów w ten sposób, gdzie odbijamy dane wejściowe i używamy bitowego XOR dla wyjścia,
jest to, że te gate'y są zawsze unitarne dla dowolnego wyboru funkcji f.
Jest to, w rzeczywistości,
operacja deterministyczna.
I gdybyśmy wyrazili ją jako macierz dla dowolnego wyboru funkcji F, otrzymalibyśmy macierz permutacji,
co oznacza macierz z jedynką w każdym wierszu i w każdej kolumnie, a wszystkie pozostałe elementy równe 0.
A macierze permutacji
są zawsze unitarne.
W rzeczywistości dla tej operacji otrzymamy, że operacja
jest swoją własną odwrotnością, więc Uf dagger równa się Uf.
Jeśli chcemy tylko używać tych
gate'ów do ewaluacji f(x) dla jakiegoś ciągu x, to jest łatwe,
możemy po prostu ustawić y
na ciąg samych zer. Więc gdy wziąć XOR bitów y, skończymy z po prostu f(x).
Tutaj nawiasem mówiąc możesz zobaczyć notację, która jest używana do oznaczenia ciągu samych zer.
Wygląda jak 0 do potęgi M, ale to nie to oznacza.
Oznacza ciąg zer
o długości równej M.
Gdy mówimy o
ciągach, a nie liczbach, wykładniki zazwyczaj oznaczają, że powtarzamy ten ciąg
pewną liczbę razy,
więc to jest 0 powtórzone m razy.
WEBVTT
To po prostu wygodny i precyzyjny sposób opisania tego ciągu.
Jeszcze raz, gdy
pracujemy z modelem zapytań, nie martwimy się o to, jak
implementować te query gate'y.
To ten sam problem,
który mieliśmy z query gate'ami dla Boolean circuit'u.
Nie naszą pracą jest przygotowanie danych wejściowych, są nam dane w
postaci tych query gate'ów.
Chcę jednak wskazać, że jeśli wiemy, jak
zaimplementować funkcję f używając Boolean circuit'u, to jest możliwe przetłumaczenie tej implementacji
dość bezpośrednio do implementacji
Uf jako quantum circuit'u, i zobaczymy dokładnie, jak
to działa w następnej lekcji.
Nawiasem mówiąc, jest dość proste stworzenie Boolean circuit'u,
który działa w ten sposób, używając pojedynczego klasycznego
query gate'u dla funkcji f,
ale to jest zupełnie inne od posiadania implementacji
quantum circuit'u tego unitarnego gate'u.
Jednak ważne jest to, że
dla klasycznych algorytmów zapytań, posiadanie query gate'u działającego w ten sposób jest faktycznie równoważne
posiadaniu zwykłego
klasycznego query gate'u dla f, w sensie że każde z nich może być zaimplementowane za pomocą drugiego.
W tej sekcji lekcji omówimy algorytm Deutscha, który jest bardzo prostym
kwantowym algorytmem zapytań, ale jest prawdziwym klejnotem.
Ten algorytm pochodzi z artykułu z 1985 roku napisanego przez Davida Deutscha, był jednym z pierwszych, którzy pracowali nad teoretycznymi
podstawami obliczeń kwantowych.
Sam algorytm stanowi bardzo małą część
artykułu Deutscha z 1985 roku, i w rzeczywistości,
algorytm, który teraz
nazywamy algorytmem Deutscha, jest faktycznie ulepszoną wersją algorytmu, który Deutsch opisał.
Dostarcza bardzo skromnego przykładu tego, jak komputery kwantowe mogą
oferować zalety obliczeniowe, ale gdzieś trzeba zacząć,
i był naprawdę ważną iskrą, która zapoczątkowała sprawy.
Algorytm Deutscha rozwiązuje problem zapytań, który jest często nazywany problemem Deutscha w kontekście obliczeń kwantowych,
ale faktycznie jest to nic innego
jak problem parzystości dla funkcji z jednego bitu do jednego bitu, o którym już rozmawialiśmy.
Jak już widzieliśmy, istnieją cztery funkcje
z jednego bitu do jednego bitu, i są opisane tutaj na ekranie za pomocą ich tabel wartości.
Pierwsza i ostatnia z tych
funkcji są stałe, podczas gdy środkowe dwie są zrównoważone w tym sensie, że dwie
możliwe wartości wyjściowe
pojawiają się tę samą liczbę razy.
Dla dwóch stałych funkcji
widzimy, że parzystość, lub innymi słowy, XOR dwóch wyjść wynosi 0,
a dla dwóch zrównoważonych funkcji, parzystość wyjść wynosi 1.
Więc równoważny sposób
opisania problemu parzystości w tym konkretnym przypadku, gdzie funkcja f przyjmuje
jeden bit jako wejście,
lub innymi słowy, problemu Deutscha, jest taki jak widzisz tutaj.
Dane wejściowe to funkcja f
z jednego bitu do jednego bitu, a wyjście to 0, jeśli f jest stała,
i 1, jeśli f jest zrównoważona.
Jak już sugerowałem, każdy klasyczny algorytm zapytań,
który rozwiązuje ten problem, musi wykonać co najmniej dwa zapytania do f.
Jeśli poznasz tylko jedną z
dwóch wartości wyjściowych f, nadal nie masz żadnej informacji o parzystości dwóch wyjść.
I to nawiasem mówiąc jest prawdą
nawet dla klasycznych algorytmów, które korzystają z losowości.
Losowość może być czasem bardzo przydatna do rozwiązywania problemów zapytań, i zobaczymy przykład
trochę później w lekcji,
ale losowość tutaj nie pomaga.
Więc nasz wcześniejszy algorytm jest optymalny wśród klasycznych algorytmów zapytań
dla problemu Deutscha.
Teraz przyjrzymy się
algorytmowi Deutscha, który jest kwantowym algorytmem zapytań rozwiązującym problem Deutscha
używając pojedynczego zapytania.
I oto algorytm
opisany jako quantum circuit.
Mamy dwa qubit'y
zainicjowane jak widzisz tutaj, z górnym zainicjowanym do ket 0 i dolnym zainicjowanym do ket 1,
i wkrótce zobaczymy, dlaczego inicjalizujemy te qubit'y w ten sposób.
Wykonujemy Hadamard
gate'y na dwóch qubit'ach, podajemy je do query gate'u, wykonujemy kolejny Hadamard
gate na górnym qubit'cie,
a następnie mierzymy go. I twierdzenie jest takie, że
wynik pomiaru daje nam z pewnością
właściwą odpowiedź na problem.
Więc przeanalizujmy
circuit krok po kroku, aby dokładnie zobaczyć, jak działa.
Stan dwóch qubit'ów po pierwszej warstwie Hadamard gate'ów to iloczyn tensorowy
stanów minus i plus.
Hadamard na górze odwzorowuje
stan 0 na stan plus, a Hadamard na dole odwzorowuje stan 1 na stan minus.
Górny qubit jest po prawej, a dolny qubit jest po lewej, więc to jest stan, który otrzymujemy.
Bardzo ważne jest, że dolny qubit jest w stanie minus, nawiasem mówiąc, to by nie działało, gdybyśmy
zainicjowali dolny qubit
do stanu 0 zamiast stanu 1.
Rozszerzymy ten stan
w połowie, jak widzisz tutaj.
Powód tego
nie jest jasny w tym momencie, ale okaże się wygodny
za chwilę.
Następnie pomyślmy o
stanie dwóch qubit'ów po wykonaniu query gate'u.
Sposób działania query gate'u
polega na tym, że oblicza F na stanie standardowej bazy
górnego qubit'a i XORuje wartość
na dolny qubit,
WEBVTT
i tutaj możemy zobaczyć
wynik tego działania.
Dla pierwszego członu, stan standardowej bazy
górnego qubit'a to 0, więc f(0) jest XORowane
na dolny qubit,
co działa przez liniowość. I jest podobnie dla drugiego członu, z wyjątkiem że stan standardowej bazy
dla górnego qubit'a to 1, więc XORujemy f(1) na dolny qubit.
I w tym momencie możemy
uprościć to wyrażenie, obserwując formułę,
którą widzisz tutaj na dole, która działa, gdy a wynosi 0 lub 1.
I możemy po prostu sprawdzić to dla tych dwóch wartości osobno.
Jeśli a jest równe 0, to
XORowanie z a nic nie robi, a ujemne 1 do potęgi 0 wynosi 1,
więc obie strony są równe. A jeśli a jest równe 1, otrzymujemy ket 1 minus ket
0, gdy bierzemy XOR,
co jest ujemne 1
razy ket 0 minus ket 1.
Jeśli użyjemy tej formuły
do uproszczenia naszego stanu, gdzie przyjmujemy a równe
f(0) po lewej i a równe f(1) po prawej,
otrzymujemy wyrażenie,
które widzisz tutaj.
Więc porównując dwa
wektory stanu kwantowego π1 i π2, widzimy, że gate Uf
efektywnie umieszcza
jedną z dwóch wartości, f(0) lub f(1), w
wykładniku ujemnego 1,
lub innymi słowy, w
fazie każdego członu.
To jest powód
inicjalizacji dolnego qubit'a do 1 i wykonania Hadamard gate'u na nim, aby utworzyć stan minus,
co pozwala temu się wydarzyć.
Nazywa się to zjawiskiem phase kickback, i wrócimy do niego za kilka chwil, żeby spojrzeć na to z innej strony.
Jest dość ważne i zobaczymy je
jeszcze kilka razy w tej lekcji, a także w późniejszych lekcjach.
Możemy teraz uprościć, wyciągając
stan minus z powrotem na zewnątrz, aby otrzymać wyrażenie,
które widzisz tutaj.
Nawiasem mówiąc, jest
dość ciekawe, że nie ma tutaj tak naprawdę
żadnego splątania.
Oba te stany są stanami produktowymi. Więc, cóż, splątanie
jest niezwykle interesujące,
ale nie odgrywa
żadnej roli w tym konkretnym algorytmie.
Uprządźmy to trochę, żebyśmy mieli nieco więcej miejsca.
To, co możemy teraz zrobić, to
wyciągnąć czynnik ujemnego 1 podniesionego do potęgi f(0) na zewnątrz,
aby otrzymać wyrażenie stanu,
które widzisz tutaj.
Zauważ, że tutaj mamy XOR z f(0) i f(1) w wykładniku ujemnego 1.
Moglibyśmy się spodziewać, że to
będzie f(1) minus f(0), ponieważ wyciągamy czynnik ujemnego 1 do potęgi f(0) na zewnątrz,
ale otrzymujemy tę samą
wartość, jeśli weźmiemy XOR, ponieważ to są bity, i jedyne, co ma znaczenie, gdy mamy liczbę całkowitą w
wykładniku ujemnego 1,
to to, czy ta liczba całkowita jest parzysta czy nieparzysta.
Innym sposobem wyrażenia tego
stanu jest tak jak tutaj, gdzie po prostu rozważamy
dwa możliwe przypadki dla XOR.
i to jest wygodny
sposób wyrażenia stanu, gdy rozważamy działanie
ostatniego Hadamard gate'u razem z pomiarem.
Gdy wykonujemy ostatni
Hadamard gate na górnym qubit'cie, stan plus jest
przekształcany w stan 0,
a stan minus jest
przekształcany w stan 1, co możemy zapisać bardziej
zwięźle w ten sposób.
I wreszcie, gdy
wykonywany jest pomiar, wynikiem, który otrzymujemy, jest
zatem XOR z f(0) i f(1),
co jest wartością, której szukamy, i tak właśnie działa algorytm Deutscha.
Jest dość prosty, a jeśli zapytamy siebie, co sprawia, że działa, pozwalając nam obliczyć
parzystość dwóch bitów
za pomocą jednego zapytania zamiast dwóch, rozsądna odpowiedź to
interferowanie.
Efektywnie
obliczamy f(0) i f(1) jednocześnie, ponieważ najpierw wykonaliśmy
Hadamard gate
na górnym qubit'cie, aby wprowadzić wejście do f w
superpozycję 0 i 1.
I dzięki phase kickback wraz z ostatnim Hadamard gate'em, zasadniczo tworzymy
konstruktywną interferencję
dla właściwej odpowiedzi i destruktywną interferencję
dla błędnej odpowiedzi.
Więc nie widzimy błędnej odpowiedzi, widzimy tylko właściwą odpowiedź.
Pozwól, że powiem trochę więcej o zjawisku phase kickback, żeby spojrzeć na to
pod nieco innym kątem.
Najpierw zauważmy
tę bardzo prostą formułę, gdzie b i c są dowolnymi wartościami binarnymi.
Krótko mówiąc, XORowanie bitu b z wartością 1 jest tym samym, co wykonanie gate'u NOT lub operacji x na b,
i oczywiście XORowanie
bitu b z wartością 0 nic z nim nie robi, co jest tym samym, co wykonanie
operacji identyczności na nim.
I możemy wyrazić operację identyczności jako x do potęgi 0.
Więc jeśli wykonamy gate Uf na dwóch qubit'ach w stanie standardowej bazy ket b tensor ket a,
otrzymujemy ten wynik, zgodnie z definicją gate'u Uf.
WEBVTT
i używając formuły, możemy alternatywnie zapisać ten stan tak, jak widzisz tutaj.
Ta formuła działa dla wszystkich wyborów b, więc przez liniowość działa
dla dowolnego stanu SI
zamiast ket b.
I w szczególności, jeśli chcemy, możemy wybrać SI jako stan minus.
I oto klucz do tego, dlaczego zjawisko phase kickback
się wydarza.
Dzieje się tak, ponieważ operacja x
zastosowana do stanu minus daje nam ujemne 1 razy stan minus.
W terminach matematycznych mówimy, że stan minus
jest wektorem własnym operacji x z wartością własną równą ujemnemu 1.
Wektory własne i wartości własne
są niezwykle ważne w algebrze liniowej, jak również
w informacji kwantowej, i będziemy mieli o nich
wiele więcej do powiedzenia
w miarę kontynuacji serii.
Ale na razie potrzebujemy
tylko tej prostej formuły.
I używając jej, możemy
uprościć nasz wektor stanu.
I to właśnie jest zasadniczo zjawisko phase kickback
zapisane jako formuła.
Działa, ponieważ stan minus
jest wektorem własnym operacji NOT mającym
wartość własną ujemną jeden.
Uogólnimy to w
dość istotny sposób w lekcji 7, gdy przejdziemy do procedury szacowania fazy, która napędza
algorytm faktoryzacji Shora.
Możemy zobaczyć tę formułę w działaniu w analizie algorytmu Deutscha
w następujący sposób.
Przed query gate'em, nasz stan to iloczyn tensorowy stanów minus i plus.
Następnie stosujemy query gate, a rozwinięcie stanu plus
daje nam ten stan.
Teraz stosujemy formułę phase kickback, aby otrzymać to wyrażenie, i następnie analiza
przebiega jak wcześniej.
Jest taka sama jak wcześniej, ale tutaj skupiamy
uwagę na phase kickback, żebyśmy mogli go rozpoznać
i byliśmy gotowi na niego
gdy pojawi się ponownie.
Następnie przejdziemy do
algorytmu Deutscha-Jozsy, który jest rozszerzeniem
algorytmu Deutscha, rozwiązującym kilka
różnych problemów zapytań.
Zaleta, którą
algorytm Deutscha zapewnia nad algorytmami klasycznymi,
jest dość skromna: jedno zapytanie versus dwa.
Algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy nieco zwiększa tę przewagę, i wyjaśnię, co przez to rozumiem,
gdy do tego dojdziemy.
Algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy można traktować jako naturalny i bezpośredni sposób rozszerzenia algorytmu Deutscha
z funkcji z jednego bitu do jednego bitu do funkcji z n bitów do jednego bitu, lub innymi słowy, funkcji tej postaci.
Jako quantum circuit, algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy
wygląda tak, i będę się do tego odwoływał jako circuit Deutscha-Jozsy
tylko żeby zaznaczyć drobną
różnicę między tym circuit'em a samym algorytmem Deutscha-Jozsy, ponieważ jest też
krok klasycznego postprzetwarzania.
Idea polega na tym, że jeśli uruchomimy
ten circuit, a następnie zmierzymy, otrzymamy jakiś ciąg n bitów y,
który mówi nam coś
o funkcji f.
W tym momencie nawiasem mówiąc nie powiedziałem jeszcze faktycznie,
jaki jest problem zapytań, który mamy nadzieję rozwiązać za pomocą tego circuit'u, to nadchodzi bardzo szybko.
Ale chodzi o to, że
uruchamiając ten circuit, zyskamy pewne informacje o f, które mogą potencjalnie pomóc
nam rozwiązywać problemy zapytań,
gdzie f jest wejściem. I jak mówiłem przed chwilą, możemy faktycznie używać tego circuit'u
do rozwiązania kilku
różnych problemów zapytań.
Najpierw przyjrzyjmy się
problemowi zapytań znany jako problem Deutscha-Jozsy, który jest problemem, który circuit Deutscha-Jozsy
był pierwotnie przeznaczony do rozwiązania.
Problem Deutscha-Jozsy jest uogólnieniem problemu Deutscha, gdzie celem jest ustalenie, czy dana funkcja
jest stała czy zrównoważona.
Zauważ, że to nie jest naturalny sposób uogólnienia problemu parzystości
do funkcji tej postaci.
Tutaj nie obliczamy parzystości, zadaniem jest wyjście 0, jeśli
funkcja f jest stała,
i 1, jeśli funkcja f jest zrównoważona.
Pierwszą rzeczą do zauważenia w związku z
tym problemem jest to, że gdy n, liczba bitów wejściowych do
funkcji f, wynosi co najmniej 2,
istnieją wybory funkcji, które nie są ani stałe, ani zrównoważone.
Na przykład tutaj jest
funkcja z 2 bitów do 1 bitu, która nie jest ani stała, ani zrównoważona.
Nie jest stała, ponieważ obie wartości binarne
pojawiają się wśród wyjść, i nie jest zrównoważona,
ponieważ dwie wartości wyjściowe
pojawiają się z różnymi częstościami. 0 pojawia się trzy razy
i 1 pojawia się tylko raz.
Aby być zrównoważoną,
wyjścia 0 i 1 muszą wystąpić dokładnie
tę samą liczbę razy.
Fakt, że istnieją funkcje, które nie są ani stałe, ani zrównoważone, gdy n wynosi co najmniej 2, jest jednak w porządku, będziemy po prostu rozważać
funkcje takie jak ta
jako dane wejściowe „nie dbamy o to". Innymi słowy, to
jest problem z obietnicą.
I oto precyzyjne
sformułowanie problemu.
WEBVTT
Obiecuje się nam, że funkcja wejściowa f jest albo stała, albo zrównoważona, i celem jest dowiedzenie się,
która z nich.
I nie ponosimy odpowiedzialności za to, co się stanie, jeśli dane wejściowe
nie spełniają obietnicy.
Algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy,
który rozwiązuje ten problem, polega najpierw na uruchomieniu circuit'u Deutscha-Jozsy, a następnie wyjście 0,
jeśli ciąg, który
otrzymujemy z pomiarów, jest ciągiem samych zer,
a w przeciwnym razie wyjście 1.
Innym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest to, że wychodzimy z OR
bitów, które mierzymy.
Aby przeanalizować algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy, warto
najpierw poświęcić chwilę na przemyślenie Hadamard gate'ów.
Możemy oczywiście opisać operację Hadamard
jako macierz, ale możemy też opisać
ją pod kątem jej działania
na stanach standardowej bazy,
jak widzisz tutaj.
Te dwa równania można
połączyć w jedno równanie, które opisuje, jak
działa operacja Hadamard dla a będącego jedną z
dwóch wartości binarnych,
i możemy pójść trochę dalej i wyrazić to, co
otrzymujemy, jako sumę w ten sposób.
Używając tej formuły, możemy opracować formułę, która opisuje, jak działa warstwa
Hadamard gate'ów, gdzie stosujemy jeden Hadamard
gate do każdego z n qubit'ów.
Tutaj opisujemy to
działanie na stanach standardowej bazy.
I żeby wyjaśnić notację, gdy piszemy h tensor n w ten sposób, gdzie część tensor n jest wykładnikiem,
mamy na myśli n-krotny
iloczyn tensorowy H z samym sobą, lub innymi słowy, n kopii
h wszystkich ze sobą tensorowanych.
Stosujemy tę operację
do stanu standardowej bazy, i tutaj stosuję
konwencję, której używa Qiskit
do indeksowania ciągów binarnych, po prostu dlatego, że to dobry moment
na wprowadzenie tej konwencji.
Więc x0 to bit, x1 to bit,
i tak dalej z n bitami łącznie, a bity są ułożone tak,
jak widzisz tutaj na ekranie.
Możesz myśleć o tym
sposobie indeksowania bitów jako odpowiadającym ich znaczeniu, jeśli traktujemy ciągi jako
reprezentujące liczby całkowite
w zapisie binarnym na przykład.
Jeśli stosujemy Hadamard gate
do każdego z tych qubit'ów, możemy alternatywnie wyrazić wynik jako n-krotny iloczyn tensorowy
Hadamard gate'u zastosowanego do każdego qubit'a, a następnie możemy zastosować naszą formułę do każdego z czynników tensorowych.
I tutaj używamy
nazw y i minus 1 w dół do y1 zamiast b w formule,
więc to są wartości binarne. I upewniamy się, że używamy nowej nazwy za każdym razem, gdy korzystamy z formuły.
Jeśli następnie rozwinięto wszystko, używając wieloliniowości
iloczynów tensorowych, otrzymujemy wyrażenie,
które widzisz tutaj.
I żeby było jasne, n sum jest
łączonych w jedną sumę, ale nadal sumujemy
po wszystkich możliwych wartościach
dla poszczególnych wartości binarnych.
Teraz uprządźmy to, żebyśmy mogli pójść trochę dalej.
A następnym krokiem jest
wprowadzenie nowej operacji na ciągach zwanej binarnym iloczynem skalarnym.
Jest to operacja na ciągach binarnych tej samej długości.
I czym jest binarny iloczyn skalarny dwóch ciągów x i y
tej samej długości? To XOR lub parzystość
iloczynów poszczególnych bitów.
Można też powiedzieć, że jest to XOR logicznego AND poszczególnych bitów, ponieważ AND jest
tym samym, co iloczyn
dla wartości binarnych. Jeszcze innym sposobem opisania
tego jest to, że wynosi 1 lub 0
w zależności od tego, czy
suma iloczynów poszczególnych bitów jest nieparzysta czy parzysta.
Przypomina to bardzo iloczyn skalarny, jeśli myślimy o ciągach
jako wektorach wartości binarnych, ale gdzie obliczamy modulo 2,
lub innymi słowy, bierzemy resztę po podzieleniu przez 2.
To nie jest jednak naprawdę iloczyn skalarny, więc zasługuje na inną nazwę.
W tym konkretnym przypadku możemy użyć binarnego iloczynu skalarnego
do uczynienia naszej formuły dla działania warstwy Hadamard gate'u
na stanach standardowej bazy bardziej zwięzłą, i oto ona tutaj.
Używamy faktu, że
ponieważ ta suma tutaj pojawia się w
wykładniku ujemnego 1,
jedyną rzeczą, która ma znaczenie, jest
to, czy jest parzysta, czy nieparzysta, ale poza tym, to jest zasadniczo tylko skróconą
wersją naszej formuły.
Nawiasem mówiąc, binarny
iloczyn skalarny jest symetryczny w tym sensie, że x·y i y·x są równe,
więc możemy swobodnie zamieniać
kolejność, gdy jest to przydatne.
I teraz, gdy mamy tę formułę, będzie dość łatwo przeanalizować
circuit Deutscha-Jozsy.
Zaczynamy od n qubit'ów w stanie 0 i dolnego qubit'a w stanie 1, i wykonujemy Hadamard
gate'y na wszystkich z nich.
Więc to jest stan
n + 1 qubit'ów, który otrzymujemy.
Traktujemy
dolny qubit oddzielnie, ponieważ tak będzie wygodniej.
I znowu zobaczymy, jak
następuje zjawisko phase kickback.
WEBVTT
Możemy otrzymać to wyrażenie
używając naszej formuły, gdzie podstawiamy ciąg samych zer za x i podstawiamy x za y,
zauważając, że binarny iloczyn skalarny ciągu samych zer z dowolnym ciągiem wynosi 0.
Ale możemy też po prostu uzasadnić to bezpośrednio. Bierzemy iloczyn tensorowy n stanów plus, i oto co otrzymujemy,
tensorując ze stanem minus. Następnie stosowany jest gate UF i tutaj właśnie zachodzi zjawisko phase kickback.
Wartość f(x) jest
XORowana na stan minus dla każdego x w sumie.
Więc f(x) jest wkopywane w fazę.
Teraz stosujemy kolejną
warstwę Hadamard gate'ów tylko do górnych n qubit'ów, i tym razem naprawdę
potrzebujemy formuły.
Gdy ją stosujemy i dokonujemy niewielkiego
uproszczenia, otrzymujemy ten stan tutaj.
Więc to jest nasz ostateczny stan tuż
przed pomiarami.
Stan wygląda trochę skomplikowanie i trudno go uprościć, ponieważ tak naprawdę nie wiemy
nic o funkcji f.
Ale pamiętaj, że wszystko,
co naprawdę musimy wiedzieć, to czy wszystkie pomiary dają wynik 0,
bo to właśnie determinuje, jaka jest nasza odpowiedź na problem.
Jeśli zobaczymy, że każdy
wynik pomiaru to 0, wnioskujemy, że funkcja jest stała.
A jeśli którykolwiek z
wyników pomiaru to 1, wnioskujemy, że funkcja jest zrównoważona.
Więc obliczmy prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania ciągu samych zer
z pomiarów.
I okazuje się, że to jedyny wynik, który jest naprawdę łatwy do obliczenia, ponieważ binarny iloczyn skalarny ciągu samych zer
z dowolnym ciągiem wynosi zero. Jeśli zbadamy nasz wektor i
pomyślimy o tym, co dzieje się, gdy y jest ciągiem samych zer,
otrzymujemy to wyrażenie tutaj
dla prawdopodobieństwa uzyskania ciągu samych zer
z pomiarów.
Rozważając dwa możliwe przypadki, gdy f jest stała i f jest zrównoważona, widzimy, że prawdopodobieństwo
uzyskania ciągu samych zer wynosi 1
w przypadku, gdy f jest stała, i zero gdy f jest zrównoważona.
Gdy f jest stała, suma wynosi albo 2 do n, albo ujemne 2 do n, i dzieląc przez 2 do n
i biorąc wartość bezwzględną
do kwadratu, otrzymujemy 1.
A gdy f jest zrównoważona, suma wynosi 0.
Dzieje się tak, ponieważ otrzymamy
plus 1 i minus 1 równą liczbę razy,
więc wszystko się znosi.
I tyle. Algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy
rozwiązuje problem Deutscha-Jozsy używając jednego zapytania,
i nie ma błędu. Zakładając, że wszystkie operacje
są wykonane idealnie, jest poprawny za każdym razem.
Jak to się ma do tego,
co możemy robić klasycznie?
Cóż, jeśli nalegamy na
deterministyczny algorytm, który za każdym razem otrzymuje właściwą odpowiedź, to w najgorszym przypadku
potrzebujemy 2 do n minus 1 plus 1 zapytań, co wynika z tego, że musimy zapytać funkcję
na więcej niż połowie jej danych wejściowych, aby być pewnym rozwiązania.
Nawet jeśli zapytamy funkcję na 2 do n minus 1
różnych ciągach wejściowych, jest możliwe, że zobaczymy tę samą wartość wyjściową
za każdym razem, i mogłoby to być dlatego,
że funkcja jest stała, lub mogłoby być, że jest faktycznie zrównoważona,
i po prostu mieliśmy niesamowitego pecha, widząc tę samą wartość wyjściową
za każdym razem.
Więc to jest ogromna przewaga
kwantowa nad klasyczną: jedno zapytanie versus
wykładniczo wiele zapytań.
Jednak jeśli użyjemy
probabilistycznego algorytmu zapytań i zaakceptujemy małe prawdopodobieństwo błędnej odpowiedzi,
to faktycznie potrzebujemy tylko kilku zapytań.
W szczególności, jeśli
losowo wybierzemy k ciągów i ewaluujemy funkcję
na tych losowych ciągach,
to jesteśmy dość skłonni móc ustalić właściwą odpowiedź.
Konkretnie, odpowiadamy 0 lub stała, gdy za każdym razem otrzymujemy tę samą wartość funkcji, i 1 lub zrównoważona,
gdy widzimy dwie
różne wartości funkcji.
Jeśli to zrobimy, zawsze będziemy mieć rację, gdy
funkcja jest stała, ponieważ oczywiście zawsze zobaczymy tę samą
wartość wyjściową w tym przypadku.
A jeśli f jest zrównoważona, jest bardzo prawdopodobne, że zobaczymy
dwie różne wartości wyjściowe.
Szansa, że nie zobaczymy
obu wartości wyjściowych w tym przypadku, jest taka sama jak szansa rzutu monetą k razy
i uzyskania za każdym razem
tego samego wyniku.
Więc na przykład, jeśli
ustawimy k równe 11, prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania błędnej odpowiedzi jest mniejsze niż jedna dziesiąta procenta.
Więc szczególnie biorąc pod uwagę fakt, że komputery kwantowe nigdy nie będą idealne w rzeczywistości, tak naprawdę nie uzyskujemy tutaj
aż tak dużej przewagi,
ale robimy postępy i mamy wymierna przewagę kwantową nad klasyczną, która wykracza poza algorytm Deutscha.
Możemy też używać circuit'u Deutscha-Jozsy do rozwiązania innego problemu zapytań zwanego problemem Bernsteina-Vaziraniego.
Oto sformułowanie tego problemu. Wejście to funkcja
z n bitów do 1 bitu, tak samo jak problem Deutscha-Jozsy,
WEBVTT
i znowu jest to problem z obietnicą.
Tym razem obietnica polega na tym, że istnieje pewien ciąg n bitów s, dla którego funkcja f
działa tak, jak widzisz tutaj,
gdzie wyjście jest dane
przez binarny iloczyn skalarny wejścia z tym ciągiem s,
a celem jest po prostu
znalezienie ciągu s. Więc możemy wyobrażać sobie, że
ciąg s jest w pewnym sensie ukryty,
ale możemy dowiedzieć się o nim,
wykonując zapytania do f, i naszym celem jest znalezienie
tego ukrytego ciągu.
Żeby było jasne, większość funkcji
nie spełni tej obietnicy, ale jak zwykle, zależy nam tylko na
funkcjach wejściowych, które ją spełniają.
Jak się okazuje, circuit Deutscha-Jozsy faktycznie rozwiązuje ten problem
od razu.
Jeśli uruchomimy go dla
funkcji takiej jak tutaj, która spełnia
obietnicę dla jakiegoś ciągu s, pomiary ujawnią ciąg s
bez żadnego postprzetwarzania.
Zobaczmy, jak to działa.
Przeanalizowaliśmy już
circuit Deutscha-Jozsy, więc możemy właściwie
przejść od razu do końca.
Oto wyrażenie, które
mieliśmy wcześniej dla stanu tuż przed pomiarami, i to wyrażenie było
ważne dla dowolnej funkcji f.
A teraz, jeśli podstawimy
to, co jest nam obiecane o funkcji f i uproszczamy,
otrzymujemy stan minus
dla dolnego qubit'a tensorowany z ket s dla górnych n qubit'ów.
I tak po pomiarze otrzymujemy s.
Jest trochę pracy do wykonania przy przeprowadzeniu uproszczeń,
które tutaj pokazałem, i nie będę przez to przechodzić w tym filmie,
ale w treści podręcznika dla tej serii jest więcej szczegółów na ten temat, które możesz znaleźć, klikając link w opisie tego filmu,
lub po prostu spróbuj samemu
dla ćwiczenia.
Więc odkryliśmy, że
circuit Deutscha-Jozsy rozwiązuje problem Bernsteina-Vaziraniego
za pomocą jednego zapytania.
Nie jest zbyt trudno pokazać,
że każdy klasyczny algorytm, czy to deterministyczny,
czy probabilistyczny, potrzebuje co najmniej n zapytań
do rozwiązania problemu Bernsteina-Vaziraniego z prostego powodu, że potrzebujemy n bitów
informacji, żeby odzyskać s,
a każde zapytanie daje nam co
najwyżej 1 bit informacji.
Więc uzyskujemy kolejną przewagę kwantową nad klasycznymi
algorytmami zapytań: jedno zapytanie dla algorytmów kwantowych,
n zapytań dla algorytmów klasycznych.
Warto poświęcić chwilę, żeby powiedzieć o
nomenklaturze używanej w kontekście tego problemu i trochę o historii.
Ludzie czasami odnoszą się do algorytmu, który właśnie opisałem, jako algorytmu Bernsteina-Vaziraniego, ale jest to właściwie po prostu
circuit Deutscha-Jozsy,
i to jest coś, co zostało,
w rzeczywistości, bardzo wyraźnie stwierdzone w pracy Bernsteina i Vaziraniego.
Więc jest trochę dziwne, że nazywa się to algorytmem Bernsteina-Vaziraniego, bo to właściwie mniej więcej to samo, co algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy,
minus postprzetwarzanie. Bernstein i Vazirani zrobili
jednak krok dalej.
Zdefiniowali rekurencyjną
wersję tego problemu, gdzie zasadniczo
musisz rozwiązywać instancje problemu Bernsteina-Vaziraniego,
żeby odblokować nowe instancje problemu, ułożone w
skomplikowany wzór przypominający drzewo.
To wysoce sztuczny problem, ale chodzi o to, że definiując problem w ten sposób, mogli efektywnie rozciągać
separację jeden versus n zapytań między kwantowym a klasycznym.
I to, co uzyskali, to
pierwsza znana przykład tak zwanej super-wielomianowej przewagi kwantowej nad algorytmami probabilistycznymi.
Ta rekurencyjna wersja problemu
Bernsteina-Vaziraniego okazała się później dużo bardziej
interesująca w teorii złożoności obliczeniowej z różnych powodów.
Tak czy inaczej, chodzi o to, że
Bernstein i Vazirani z pewnością zasługują na uznanie za swoje ważne wkłady,
ale naprawdę nie ma
sensu nazywać tego algorytmem Bernsteina-Vaziraniego, to zasadniczo po prostu
algorytm Deutscha-Jozsy.
W ostatniej części lekcji przyjrzymy się jeszcze
jednemu kwantowemu algorytmowi zapytań, zwanemu algorytmem Simona.
Zobaczysz wyraźne podobieństwo
między tym algorytmem a algorytmem Deutscha-Jozsy, ale jest inny, a co ważniejsze,
ujawnia o wiele silniejszą przewagę kwantową nad klasycznymi
algorytmami zapytań.
Konkretnie, daje nam
dowodliwą wykładniczą przewagę kwantową nad algorytmami klasycznymi, nawet probabilistycznymi.
Problem, który rozwiązuje, jest nieco sztuczny i trudno sobie wyobrazić sytuację, w której rozwiązanie tego
problemu byłoby przydatne,
ale bezpośrednio zainspirowało
odkrycie przez Petera Shora kwantowego algorytmu
dla faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych,
co bardzo mocno wspiera
tę ideę modelu zapytań jako szalki Petriego, w której można rozwijać
kwantowe idee algorytmiczne.
Zacznijmy od problemu zapytań, który rozwiązuje algorytm Simona, który, jak można się domyślić,
nazywa się problemem Simona.
Oto sformułowanie problemu i będziemy musieli je rozwinąć, żeby zrozumieć, o co chodzi.
Pierwszą rzeczą do
zauważenia jest to, że tym razem funkcja wejściowa f odwzorowuje ciągi
n bitów na ciągi m bitów,
gdzie m jest pewną dodatnią liczbą całkowitą, która generalnie nie jest równa jeden.
WEBVTT
To problem z obietnicą. I podobnie jak problem Bernsteina-Vaziraniego, obietnica obejmuje jakiś ciąg s, który możemy traktować jako ukryty ciąg,
i podobnie jak w problemie
Bernsteina-Vaziraniego, celem jest wypisanie
tego ukrytego ciągu s.
Tym razem obietnica jest
jednak bardziej skomplikowana, więc rozłóżmy ją na części i
zrozummy, co mówi.
Na początek po prostu ją przeczytajmy. Mówi, że istnieje ciąg s o długości równej n
taki, że pewien warunek „jeśli"
i „tylko jeśli" jest prawdziwy dla wszystkich wyborów ciągów n bitów x i y.
Konkretnie musi
być tak, że f(x) jest równe f(y) wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy zachodzi jedna z
dwóch możliwości.
Pierwsza możliwość to x równa się y, a drugą możliwością jest to, że biorąc
bitowy XOR x
z ukrytym ciągiem s, otrzymujemy y.
Okazuje się, że jest to
dość surowa obietnica w tym sensie, że większość
funkcji jej nie spełni.
Tylko bardzo specjalne funkcje
spełniają ten warunek.
Teraz, żeby lepiej zrozumieć tę obietnicę, a więc i sam problem, rozważymy dwa główne przypadki.
Pierwszym przypadkiem jest to, że s
jest ciągiem samych zer.
W tym przypadku możemy uprościć warunek „jeśli"
i „tylko jeśli" w obietnicy, ponieważ bitowy
XOR dowolnego ciągu x
z ciągiem samych zer
jest po prostu ciągiem x.
Więc warunek upraszcza się
do f(x) jest równe f(y) wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy x równa się y.
I to jest tylko inny sposób powiedzenia, że f jest funkcją różnowartościową (jeden do jednego).
Innymi słowy, ciąg f(x) musi być unikatowy
dla każdego możliwego ciągu x.
Więc jeśli f jest funkcją różnowartościową, to obietnica jest rzeczywiście spełniona, konkretnie dla s będącego
ciągiem samych zer,
i w tym przypadku to
jest prawidłowe wyjście.
Drugi przypadek jest taki, że s
nie jest ciągiem samych zer i co to implikuje, że funkcja f musi być dwójkowa (dwa do jednego).
Więc dla każdego wejściowego ciągu x istnieje dokładnie jeden inny ciąg, do którego f odwzorowuje ten sam
ciąg co x,
i co więcej, ten drugi ciąg
musi być ciągiem, który otrzymujemy biorąc bitowy
XOR x z s.
Innym sposobem powiedzenia tego
jest to, że każdy ciąg n bitów x ma partnera i tym partnerem jest ciąg, który otrzymujemy,
biorąc bitowy XOR z s.
Każda para partnerów musi dawać
nam ten sam ciąg wyjściowy, gdy podajemy je do f, i żadne inne ciągi nie mogą dawać nam
tego samego ciągu wyjściowego.
Więc to są koniecznie różne ciągi, które produkują partnerzy.
Oto przykład takiej funkcji opisanej przez jej tabelę wartości.
Więc jest to funkcja
z 3 bitów do 5 bitów.
Jeśli przyjrzymy się tej tabeli
wartości przez chwilę, odkryjemy, że obietnica jest
spełniona dla ciągu 011.
000 i 011 są partnerami. XORowanie któregokolwiek z nich
przez s daje nam ten drugi,
i przyjmują tę samą wartość wyjściową, którą jest 10011 w tym konkretnym przypadku, i żadne inne ciągi nie produkują
tego samego ciągu wyjściowego.
001 i 010 są partnerami, ponieważ XORowanie któregokolwiek z nich
przez s daje ten drugi, i produkują tę samą wartość wyjściową,
która z kolei nie jest produkowana
przez żaden inny ciąg.
I sytuacja jest
podobna dla 100 i 111, a także 101 i 110.
Więc jeśli dane wejściowe do problemu
to ta funkcja, prawidłowa odpowiedź to ciąg 011.
Jak powiedziałem wcześniej, większość funkcji nie spełnia tej obietnicy, to bardzo specyficzny warunek.
Należy też zauważyć, że
jeśli obietnica jest spełniona, może być spełniona tylko dla jednego ciągu s.
Więc zawsze jest tylko jedna
prawidłowa odpowiedź na ten problem.
I to jest problem Simona. Jak mówiłem, trudno sobie wyobrazić praktyczną sytuację, w której chciałbyś rozwiązać ten problem,
ale to nie o to chodzi. Chodzi o próbę ustalenia, w czym komputery kwantowe są dobre, i okazuje się, że są znacznie lepsze
od algorytmów klasycznych w
rozwiązywaniu tego konkretnego problemu.
Teraz przyjrzyjmy się
algorytmowi Simona, który rozwiązuje problem Simona.
Algorytm polega na
uruchamianiu quantum circuit'u, który widzisz tutaj, kilka razy, a następnie klasycznym
kroku postprzetwarzania,
i będziemy bardziej konkretni co do tego, ile
razy oznacza „kilka razy" nieco później.
Circuit wygląda bardzo podobnie
do circuit'u Deutscha-Jozsy, tym razem ponieważ funkcja
f odwzorowuje n bitów na m bitów,
query gate jest inny. Zamiast tylko jednego
qubit'a na dole, mamy teraz m qubit'ów na dole,
i n na górze jak wcześniej.
Kluczową różnicą jest to, że nie
ustawiamy stanu minus ani wielu stanów minus na dole.
Te dolne qubit'y są wszystkie
inicjalizowane do stanu 0, i te stany idą prosto
do query gate'u.
WEBVTT
Więc w tym algorytmie nie będzie żadnego phase kickback, po prostu nie tak ten działa.
Poza różnicami,
które właśnie wymieniłem, wygląda bardzo podobnie do
circuit'u Deutscha-Jozsy.
Stosujemy warstwę Hadamard gate'ów, następnie stosujemy query gate jeden raz, a następnie stosujemy kolejną
warstwę Hadamard gate'ów,
a po niej pomiary standardowej bazy górnych n qubit'ów.
Idea polega na tym, że za każdym razem, gdy
uruchamiamy ten circuit i mierzymy, otrzymamy jakiś ciąg y, który mówi nam coś
o ukrytym ciągu s
w problemie Simona. I uruchamiając circuit
kilka razy niezależnie, zbierzemy wystarczające
dowody statystyczne o s,
żeby móc ustalić, czym jest,
z dużą pewnością.
Teraz przeanalizujmy quantum
circuit dla algorytmu Simona, żeby zobaczyć, co robi.
Stan po pierwszej
warstwie Hadamard gate'ów wygląda tak, podobnie do tego, co mieliśmy dla
algorytmu Deutscha-Jozsy.
Z tą różnicą, że tym razem dolne m qubit'ów są wszystkie w stanie 0
zamiast w stanach minus.
Po wykonaniu query gate'u widzimy, że wartość f(x) została zapisana na
dolnych lub skrajnie lewych m qubit'ach,
ponieważ f(x) zostało XORowane na ciąg samych zer.
Więc znowu, w tym algorytmie nie ma phase kickback.
Następnie wykonujemy drugą
warstwę Hadamard gate'ów.
I używając tej samej formuły co wcześniej dla działania warstwy
Hadamard gate'ów na stanie standardowej bazy,
ket x w tym przypadku,
tak jak w oryginalnej formule, otrzymujemy ten stan tutaj, gdzie działanie Hadamard gate'ów
stało się bardziej widoczne. Ale jeśli chcemy, możemy też zapisać stan
w bardziej zwartej postaci, jak tutaj.
W tym momencie mierzymy górne n qubit'ów, aby uzyskać jakiś ciąg y z n bitami, i musimy tylko ustalić, jakie są prawdopodobieństwa
dla różnych ciągów. I to pomoże nam zrozumieć,
jakie informacje uzyskujemy z tego ciągu y o ciągu s
ukrytym wewnątrz funkcji f.
Będziemy potrzebować
trochę więcej miejsca na to, i naprawdę nie potrzebujemy już
diagramu circuit'u, więc pozbądźmy się go i dajmy sobie trochę
więcej przestrzeni do analizy.
Oto stan tuż
przed pomiarami, którymi są pomiary standardowej bazy górnych lub skrajnie prawych n qubit'ów.
Więc pomiar
odpowiada drugiemu ket'owi.
Oznaczmy przez p(y) prawdopodobieństwo, że pomiary dają nam ciąg y dla każdego możliwego y.
Jeśli postępujemy zgodnie z regułami z lekcji 2, otrzymujemy, że każde z tych prawdopodobieństw to kwadrat normy euklidesowej wektora tensorowanego do stanu standardowej bazy,
odpowiadającego why
w naszym wektorze stanu kwantowego.
To daje nam to wyrażenie tutaj.
Teraz, żeby lepiej zrozumieć
te prawdopodobieństwa, będziemy musieli korzystać z pewnej notacji, z którą możesz już być zaznajomiony,
bo jest dość powszechna w matematyce.
Po pierwsze, gdy mówimy o
zakresie funkcji f, mamy na myśli po prostu zbiór wszystkich ciągów, które mogą wyjść z tej funkcji.
Więc to jest zbiór wszystkich f(x) po wszystkich możliwych
wyborach wejściowego ciągu x.
Po drugie, będziemy używać tej notacji, którą widzisz tutaj, do oznaczenia zbioru wszystkich wejściowych ciągów x,
które f odwzorowuje na dany ciąg z, dla dowolnego wyboru
z, który chcemy rozważyć.
Wygląda to trochę jak
odwrotność funkcji f, ale nie jest to naprawdę odwrotność, ponieważ f niekoniecznie jest odwracalna.
Widzimy też, że po lewej stronie argumentu mamy
zbiór, i w tym przypadku jest to zbiór zawierający
tylko jeden ciąg z,
i to jest wskazówka, której potrzebujemy, żeby rozpoznać, że nie mówimy o
odwrotności funkcji f; to się nazywa przeciwobraz.
Przeciwobraz może być
zdefiniowany bardziej ogólnie dla dowolnego zbioru podanego jako argument, nie tylko zbioru zawierającego
jeden element,
ale tego właśnie będziemy potrzebować. To nie jest najlepsza
notacja na świecie, ponieważ łatwo
ją pomylić z odwrotnością,
ale jest wystarczająco jasna
i jest powszechnie używana, więc idziemy z nią.
A teraz, jeśli użyjemy tej notacji, możemy przepisać wektor, z którego bierzemy kwadrat normy euklidesowej, żeby uzyskać prawdopodobieństwo
pomiaru każdego ciągu y.
Robimy to, ponieważ musimy zobaczyć,
jakie są współczynniki dla każdego indywidualnego stanu standardowej bazy, i nie jest to jasne z
tego wyrażenia tutaj,
bo ogólnie rzecz biorąc, możemy
mieć wiele wyborów x dających ten sam ciąg f(x).
Zasadniczo wszystko, co robimy,
to dzielimy sumę po x, najpierw sumując po wszystkich
z w zakresie f,
a następnie wewnątrz tej sumy, sumując po wszystkich x w przeciwobrazie z, lub mówiąc dokładniej,
przeciwobrazie zbioru
zawierającego ciąg z.
To pozwala nam zastąpić f(x) przez z wewnątrz ket'u tutaj.
I suma po wszystkich różnych ciągach
x, które f odwzorowuje na każde z, są zbierane we współczynnik dla każdego ket'u.
Zasadniczo umieszczamy ciągi w pojemnikach, sumujemy po pojemnikach, a następnie sumujemy po
ciągach w każdym pojemniku,
WEBVTT
ale to jest równoważne po prostu
sumowaniu po wszystkich ciągach.
Więc faktycznie otrzymujemy wyrażenie równoważne temu,
od którego zaczęliśmy,
i teraz możemy obliczyć
kwadrat normy euklidesowej.
To po prostu suma kwadratów wartości bezwzględnych
współczynników, i tak otrzymujemy to wyrażenie tutaj
dla naszych prawdopodobieństw.
Oczywiście daj sobie
czas na sprawdzenie tego, jeśli zdecydujesz się to zrobić, przyzwyczajenie się do tego wszystkiego zajmuje czas
i umiejętność wykonywania
tych obliczeń, i im więcej ćwiczeń sobie dasz, tym łatwiej będzie.
Do tej pory tak naprawdę
w ogóle nie korzystaliśmy z obietnicy w problemie Simona.
Nasza analiza tych prawdopodobieństw faktycznie działa dla dowolnej funkcji f, ale teraz czas pomyśleć konkretnie o problemie Simona.
Podzielimy to na te same dwa przypadki,
które mieliśmy wcześniej.
Pierwszym przypadkiem jest to, że s
jest ciągiem samych zer, a drugim jest to, że
s nie jest ciągiem samych zer.
W pierwszym przypadku, gdy
s jest ciągiem samych zer, sprawy są dość proste.
W tym przypadku, jak widzieliśmy wcześniej, mamy, że f jest funkcją różnowartościową, więc istnieje pojedynczy ciąg x
który jest odwzorowywany na każdy z
ciągów z w zakresie f.
To sprawia, że kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej sumy po tych ciągach wynosi 1, ponieważ w sumie jest tylko
jeden człon,
to jest albo plus 1 albo minus 1, ale nie ma to znaczenia, ponieważ bierzemy
kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej i tak otrzymujemy jeden.
Jest 2 do n
elementów w zakresie f, i wiemy to, ponieważ f jest różnowartościowa, więc istnieje jeden ciąg w
zakresie dla każdego wejściowego ciągu.
Jeśli ewaluujemy całe wyrażenie, stwierdzamy, że każdy ciąg y pojawia się z prawdopodobieństwem
jeden do 2 do n.
Innymi słowy,
pomiary dają nam ciąg y wybrany równomiernie losowo.
Może się to nie wydawać aż tak przydatne, ale faktycznie będziemy mogli
odróżnić to zachowanie od zachowania, które uzyskamy w przypadku,
gdy s nie jest ciągiem samych zer, i wkrótce zobaczymy, jak to przebiega.
Na razie jednak po prostu obserwujemy, że jeśli
f spełnia obietnicę w problemie Simona w przypadku, gdy s jest ciągiem samych zer,
to wynik pomiarów jest równomiernym losowym ciągiem.
Teraz przejdźmy do drugiego przypadku, który polega na tym, że obietnica
jest spełniona dla ciągu s, który nie jest ciągiem samych zer.
W tym przypadku, jak omówiliśmy wcześniej, każdy ciąg z w zakresie f ma dokładnie dwa ciągi, które go odwzorowują,
ponieważ każdy ciąg ma partnera, a każda para partnerów
odwzorowuje na jakiś unikatowy ciąg, i konkretnie partner każdego ciągu
to ciąg, który otrzymujemy przez XORowanie z s.
Więc jeśli wybierzemy dowolny ciąg
z w zakresie f i nazwiemy w jednym z
ciągów, które f odwzorowuje na z,
to XOR z w i s jest
drugim ciągiem, który odwzorowuje się na z.
Patrząc tylko na jeden człon naszej sumy, który odpowiada jakiemukolwiek ciągowi z w zakresie, który mamy na myśli,
widzimy, że możemy
zapisać go bardziej jawnie, jak tutaj.
Mamy dwa ciągi w przeciwobrazie z, w i w XOR z s.
Możemy więc zapisać sumę
tak jak widzisz na ekranie, a teraz możemy wyciągnąć czynnik
ujemnego 1 do potęgi w.y.
Ten czynnik będzie
albo plus 1 albo minus 1, więc znika, gdy
bierzemy wartość bezwzględną,
a zostaje nam
to wyrażenie tutaj.
Szczegóły nie są tutaj wszystkie pokazane i niekoniecznie
jest oczywiste, że tak to działa, ale możesz sprawdzić, że te
dwa wyrażenia są równe,
wracając do definicji
binarnego iloczynu skalarnego i myśląc o tym, co dzieje się, gdy te rzeczy są w
wykładniku ujemnego 1,
podobnie jak to, co mieliśmy dla
problemu Bernsteina-Vaziraniego.
Wreszcie możemy rozbić to
wyrażenie na dwa przypadki.
Wynosi 4, gdy binarny iloczyn skalarny
s i y wynosi 0, i wynosi 0, gdy binarny
iloczyn skalarny s i y wynosi 1.
Zauważ w szczególności, że
nie ma tu wcale zależności od w ani z, zależy tylko od s i y.
Dzieje się tak z powodu
bardzo specyficznej i szczególnej natury obietnicy.
W istocie dlatego obietnica została sformułowana w ten sposób, żeby wszystko się tak ułożyło.
Znowu, każdy ciąg ma partnera, którego otrzymujemy przez XORowanie z
tym jednym ukrytym ciągiem s,
i to właśnie sprawia, że to wszystko się dzieje.
Możemy teraz wrócić do
wyrażenia prawdopodobieństw i wstawić wartości.
Gdy s nie jest ciągiem samych zer, istnieje 2 do n minus 1
elementów w zakresie f,
czyli połowa
liczby wejściowych ciągów, i wstawienie
wartości, które właśnie obliczyliśmy, daje tę formułę tutaj.
Więc tym razem y nie jest
całkowicie losowym ciągiem, ale raczej y jest jednostajny na dokładnie połowie ciągów n bitów,
WEBVTT
i konkretnie jest
jednostajny na tych ciągach, które mają binarny iloczyn skalarny równy 0 z s.
Teraz, gdy wiemy, jak działa circuit
dla algorytmu Simona i konkretnie jakie są prawdopodobieństwa dla różnych wyników pomiarów,
pozostaje wyjaśnić, jak to pomaga nam rozwiązać problem Simona.
Podsumowując, czego się właśnie nauczyliśmy: jeśli funkcja f spełnia obietnicę w problemie Simona,
gdy ukryty ciąg s
jest ciągiem samych zer, otrzymujemy całkowicie losowy
ciąg z pomiarów,
gdzie każdy ciąg y z n bitami
jest jednakowo prawdopodobny.
Jeśli z drugiej strony, funkcja f spełnia obietnicę dla innego ciągu s, takiego, który nie jest równy
ciągowi samych zer,
to otrzymujemy losowy ciąg y mający binarny iloczyn skalarny
równy 0 z s, i wśród wszystkich tych ciągów,
każde y jest jednakowo prawdopodobne.
Ale nigdy nie otrzymamy ciągu y mającego binarny iloczyn skalarny
równy 1 z s.
Pytanie brzmi: „Czy to wystarczy informacji,
żeby określić s?" I odpowiedź, jak już
sugerowałem, brzmi tak,
pod warunkiem, że uruchomimy
circuit wystarczającą liczbę razy.
Konkretnie, załóżmy,
że uruchamiamy circuit k razy, gdzie K jest równe n plus r,
gdzie r jest pewną liczbą, która będzie kontrolować
prawdopodobieństwo odzyskania s.
Tylko dla przykładu, jeśli
wybierzemy r równe 10, będziemy skuteczni z
prawdopodobieństwem większym niż 99,9%,
więc r nie musi być aż tak duże.
Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, prawdopodobieństwo niepowodzenia jest mniejsze niż prawdopodobieństwo
rzutu uczciwą monetą r razy i za każdym razem wypadnięcia orła.
Więc jeśli 99,9% nie jest wystarczające,
weź r równe 20, a szansa niepowodzenia jest
mniejsza niż jeden na milion,
lub wybierz jakiekolwiek r,
które ci odpowiada. Nie możesz zagwarantować poprawnego rozwiązania, ale możesz sprawić, żeby prawdopodobieństwo błędu było zaniedbywalne
dla wszelkich celów praktycznych.
Tutaj nazwiemy te
ciągi y1 do yk, gdzie używamy indeksów górnych, żeby móc je nazwać,
po to, żebyśmy mogli zarezerwować indeksy dolne do odnoszenia się do poszczególnych
bitów tych ciągów.
Więc to nie są wykładniki
ani nic podobnego, to po prostu nazwy, które nadajemy tym k ciągom.
Każdy ma długość n, ponieważ uzyskaliśmy je
z uruchamiania circuit'u dla algorytmu Simona.
Możemy więc zapisać
poszczególne bity tych k ciągów, jak widzisz tutaj.
Co teraz robimy, to tworzymy macierz m, gdzie każdy element tej macierzy to bit, i te bity bierzemy z ciągów,
które właśnie zmierzyliśmy, tak jak pokazano tutaj.
Więc ta macierz ma k wierszy i n kolumn, a jej elementy są wszystkie wartościami binarnymi.
Nie wiemy, czym jest s. To właśnie staramy się znaleźć, ale wyobraź sobie na chwilę, że wiemy, czym jest s,
i uformowaliśmy wektor kolumnowy
z bitów s, tak jak pokazano tutaj.
Gdybyśmy pomnożyli ten wektor przez m, a następnie wzięli wynik modulo 2, lub inny sposób powiedzenia tego
to taki, że zastępujemy dodawanie
przez XOR, to koniecznie
otrzymamy wektor samych zer.
Dzieje się tak, ponieważ każdy z
elementów w tym wynikającym wektorze to nic innego jak binarny iloczyn skalarny s
z jednym z wierszy m.
Jeśli S jest ciągiem samych zer, zawsze otrzymamy wektor zerowy z binarnego iloczynu skalarnego.
A jeśli s nie jest ciągiem samych zer, otrzymamy to z tego, co wiemy
o prawdopodobieństwach, dla których ciągi y1 do yk mają się pojawić.
W szczególności binarny iloczyn skalarny z s zawsze wynosi zero dla wszystkich tych ciągów.
Prostym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest to, że ten wektor
uformowany z bitów s zawsze jest w jądrze macierzy m,
zakładając, że robimy całą arytmetykę modulo 2, ale oczywiście nie wiemy, czym jest s,
staramy się znaleźć s.
Ale to, co możemy zrobić, to obliczyć
jądro tej macierzy m, znowu modulo 2.
Konkretnie możemy to zrobić używając techniki
eliminacji Gaussa, która jest procedurą, która jest często nauczana
na wstępnych kursach algebry liniowej.
Działa doskonale, gdy robimy całą arytmetykę modulo 2 i można to zrobić całkiem
wydajnie na komputerze.
I jeśli obliczymy jądro m, biorąc pod uwagę konkretny sposób, w jaki te k ciągów
zostało losowo wybranych,
będziemy w stanie odzyskać s z prawdopodobieństwem większym niż
1 minus 2 do ujemnego r.
Konkretnie, z prawdopodobieństwem większym niż
1 minus 2 do ujemnego r zobaczymy, że jądro
zawiera wektor zerowy,
jak zawsze dla każdej macierzy, a także wektor odpowiadający s, czy to jest wektor zerowy czy nie.
A co najważniejsze, żadne inne wektory nie będą
pojawiać się w jądrze.
Właściwie nie jest zbyt trudno to udowodnić, choć nie będę przez to przechodzić szczegółowo.
WEBVTT
Idea polega na tym, że jeśli
mamy jakiś inny ciąg, który nie jest wektorem zerowym
i nie jest s, to każdy z losowych
ciągów y1 do yk,
zasadniczo wyrzuci go
z jądra z prawdopodobieństwem połowy.
Więc po k próbach, jest
mało prawdopodobne, żeby przetrwał, i w rzeczywistości żaden z
ciągów, które nie należą,
nie ma szans przetrwać. I bardzo prosty fakt
z teorii prawdopodobieństwa, znany jako ograniczenie unii, może
być użyty do ustalenia tego.
Nie wyjaśniłem tutaj wszystkich
szczegółów, ale mam nadzieję, że rozumiesz, że obliczając jądro modulo 2 tej macierzy m,
z dużym prawdopodobieństwem odzyskamy s, i tak algorytm Simona
rozwiązuje problem Simona.
Jest jeszcze jedna rzecz do powiedzenia
o problemie Simona i dotyczy klasycznej
trudności tego problemu,
czyli ile zapytań potrzebuje klasyczny algorytm zapytań, żeby rozwiązać problem Simona?
Odpowiedź brzmi: dużo, ogólnie rzecz biorąc.
Istnieją różne precyzyjne
stwierdzenia, które można sformułować na temat klasycznej
trudności tego problemu, i oto jedno z nich.
Jeśli mamy jakikolwiek probabilistyczny
algorytm zapytań, który wykonuje mniej niż 2 do potęgi n przez 2
minus 1, minus 1 zapytań,
czyli liczbę zapytań
wykładniczą w n, to ten algorytm nie rozwiąże problemu Simona,
z prawdopodobieństwem co najmniej połowy.
Czasami udowodnienie
wyników niemożliwości takich jak ten może być bardzo trudne, ale ten nie jest zbyt trudny do udowodnienia
przez elementarną
analizę probabilistyczną.
Nie zrobię tego w tej wideo lekcji i skupię się zamiast tego
na intuicji za tym.
Staramy się znaleźć ukryty ciąg s, ale dopóki nie zapytamy funkcji na dwóch ciągach mających
tę samą wartość wyjściową,
uzyskamy bardzo ograniczone
informacje o s.
Zasadniczo wszystko, czego się uczymy, to
to, że ukryty ciąg s nie jest XOR żadnych dwóch różnych
ciągów, które zapytaliśmy,
a jeśli zapytamy funkcję o mniej niż tę liczbę zapytań, nadal będzie wiele możliwych wyborów s,
które nie zostały wykluczone.
To nie jest formalny dowód,
ale to jest podstawowa idea.
Podsumowując, algorytm Simona zapewnia nam uderzającą przewagę kwantową nad algorytmami klasycznymi
w modelu zapytań.
W szczególności algorytm Simona
rozwiązuje problem Simona z liczbą zapytań liniową w liczbie bitów wejściowych n do naszej funkcji,
podczas gdy każdy algorytm klasyczny,
nawet jeśli jest probabilistyczny, musi wykonać liczbę
zapytań wykładniczą w n,
żeby rozwiązać problem Simona z rozsądnym prawdopodobieństwem sukcesu.
Prawdą jest, że problem Simona jest nieco sztucznym problemem, który prawdopodobnie nikt
naprawdę nie chce rozwiązywać,
ale to jest drugorzędne. Czasami idee muszą być rozwinięte zanim zostaną wprowadzone w życie.
I rzeczywiście, Peter Shor wyraźnie stwierdził, że to właśnie algorytm Simona zainspirował jego słynny teraz algorytm kwantowy
dla faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych, który zobaczymy za kilka lekcji.
I to jest koniec lekcji 5.
W tej lekcji przyjrzeliśmy się
modelowi zapytań obliczeniowych i widzieliśmy progresję przykładów
algorytmów kwantowych,
które wykazują przewagi nad algorytmami klasycznymi
w tym modelu.
W rzeczywistości wiadomo o tym modelu
znacznie więcej i istnieją algorytmy kwantowe dla innych problemów, których
nie omówiłem.
Więc jeśli uważasz, że ten
model jest interesujący, jest całkiem sporo
więcej do nauczenia się o nim.
Naszym następnym krokiem będzie odejście
od modelu zapytań i przejście do modelu obliczeń,
który jest bardziej reprezentatywny
dla rodzajów problemów, które mamy nadzieję rozwiązywać w praktyce.
Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie na lekcji 6, gdzie skupimy się głównie na
tworzeniu fundamentów do badania algorytmów kwantowych.
A stąd przejdziemy do
konkretnych algorytmów kwantowych, w tym algorytmu Shora
dla faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych
w kolejnych lekcjach. Do widzenia do tego czasu!